Hey, have you heard that legend?
They say a girl died here at the school during the school
festival.
Her class was hosting the maid cafe when she tripped and
fell down the stairs.
Well, some say she tripped, and others say she was pushed by
some jealous classmates.
Because, you know, apparently she was an up-and-coming idol
and was about to debut in a popular idol group.
true and now they say if you come to this classroom at night
you might catch her practicing for her debut a debut that
will never come pretty creepy right
I love you.
My bad pasty, my heart My badminton When I lost My first
ever My heart With so many more I was always For so many
more And so many more I loved my But I lost my My badminton
With a total
Are you enjoying the show?
Are you here to watch the ghost of the classroom?
who who so tragically lost their lives are you wondering was
she pushed or was she or did she trip like the clumsy girl
that she is hmm I don't know some things are better left
unsaid maybe I didn't trip How could you say that?
How could you say that?
How could you just assume that I tripped?
You don't know me.
But fine, I'll give you a show if that's what you so desire.
I'm not alone, but there's no place for me to be alone.
We're all together together, love each other.
I'm going to flash you back, say me no more.
I'm never going to see you again.
I'm going to tear you together.
I'm going to keep holding you.
The summer's gone to the white-haired, young girl and a
little bit of a feeling I feel like I'm so tired of feeling
The whole world starts to get off, the start of the new
year.
The new year, the new year old, the new year I was the one
who was It's not bad, just look at me, look at me.
So, your pain and your pain are so good.
I'm sorry for the pain that's all I give to you.
I'm so sorry.
The wist of the monsters, my heart, my heart, my heart is
broken.
I'm sorry for the things that are so bad.
of the sky.
The summer's cold, the heat is the cold.
The room's window is the blue sky.
You're the same.
So, you're my friend, my friend, my friend so, If you don't
know where you're going to be.
There's no place to be.
If you love the world and love each other.
If you love each other, I'll repeat it again.
Flashback, the me and the voice I hope never will be back.
It will be forever and forever The key holder
Unfroze Unfroze Unfroze
For some reason, I can't turn my head.
Is it because I broke my neck in the fall?
Who knows?
Creepy, creepy, creepy, creepy.
So scary.
Creepy and scary.
Oh, I'm falling through the floor.
It's just ghost things.
If anything is strange, if anything is strange, it's just
because I'm a ghost.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry how scary it is.
I know, but it's very frightening.
You are probably so frightened right now.
I go back to my original position.
Nothing strange here.
Just a ghost who never got to fulfill a dream.
It is strange, though.
I can't turn my head.
I don't know why.
stream is so scuffed just go along with it okay guys just go
along just I wish I could look at you and be like hey you
looking through the the door is this what you wanted to see
you you found your ghostly rumor there urban legend now what
you're spying on me you creep you're spying on me you creep
yeah you you can't look at it in the eye for some reason uh
everything is failing on me today so uh i'm just gonna go
for it i'm just i'm just i'm just going for it yeah
here let me just let me see if i could just turn my body
i'll look at you that way Wait, why am I sideways?
Wait, what's happening to me?
Oh, that doesn't help.
Everything sucks today, guys.
Oh, wait.
I was so high up for some reason.
I can't help it.
I'm a ghost.
I'm floating around.
There we go.
Okay, here's your show.
Here's your show.
Or something.
I don't know.
Creepy summer karaoke in the classroom.
But maybe the songs aren't so creepy.
Some of them are at least.
Some of them are not.
Definitely spooky?
What if I turn my round?
This is my oh my wow!
You two touch my meokuta Mabushikuta It's too long It's
always been It's always It's always It's always It's been a
lot of things
I don't know how to fly.
I don't know how to fly, but I'll be able to hear it.
But I'll never hear the wind, but I'll hear it.
I'll know where it will be.
I'm always looking at my own dreams.
I'm looking at my children.
The children are on the summer's path.
I'm walking through the wind.
I'm on my feet.
Why
don't you do more 3D things, Mito?
That's the way the moon is the same.
The moon and the moon are the same.
It's the right
place to go.
The world will change its way.
The sun will change its shape.
We all remember.
We are all the same.
One second, sorry.
Minto of the floor, what is your wisdom?
If nothing works, just stay in the floor.
Okay, back to singing.
Oh my god, recently I got this thing on my recommended I got
this video that was like 17 years old on my recommended
timeline and it was, it was, uh, uh, oh my gosh, what was
the song?
The, yeah, it was really old.
It was really, really old.
It was, it was so funny because I, I can't stop listening to
it because it's so funny, but it's so awesome.
It's that song, the God Isn't Awesome God song, but it's a
techno remix so it starts out all holy and it's like oh and
then in the middle you skip to and it's like our god is an
awesome god kids i
go around playing make am i and i'm like
it's so funny
it's great even better because the music video not the music
video but the video like the person whoever uploaded it put
together it's so
be a meme but back then it was like serious and it's like
it's so it's so good it's so god tear you tuples i know it's
so funny i love i love it i just oh
it was a simpler time wasn't it that is that is the right
way to put it hold on um actually i don't care if i don't
care if my anymore
it will be bad eventually um you're just gonna have to wait
until i'm done being a ghost in the floor to you you're
gonna have to wait an announcement what could it be what
could it be well i'm gonna scoot up again wait uh wait
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wrong, wrong thing.
Uh, where'd I go?
There.
Oh, no, I don't want to go up.
I want to stay in the floor.
I give up trying everything that I was doing before.
Thank you guys for...
I know you guys say you don't mind the scuff, but it's so
frustrating when you're trying to do something and it
doesn't work.
I've been thinking, troubleshooting.
I hate 3D.
It's my least favorite thing ever.
Anyway, let's sing another song.
Summer songs only today, everybody.
Summer songs.
Let's see.
Yeah, Cheggie, you would know, you would know.
Who would choose 3D as their full-time job?
That would be the worst thing ever.
That would be the worst thing ever to do 3D as their job.
Yeah, all songs are very spooky.
Very, very spooky, very spooky.
This one's spooky, too.
You and the summer's end, the future's dream, a big hope, I
won't forget.
10 years later, 8 months, I'll be able to see you.
Believe in the best.
A
little bit of a sudden, on the back of the At the end of the
day, I heard a voice and said, Let's go back I'm so glad I'm
so happy with my back in my face with my face, I'm so very,
very very happy I'm so I'm so beautiful, I'm so happy Ah,
the wind is Time and time will be the same.
It's
the end, the future's dream, a big hope, I won't forget.
10 years ago, 8 years ago,
I know you.
I'm in my heart, I'm in my smile, I'm in my sense,
my summer's a long time, and I'm in my life, I'm in my life,
and I'm in my love, love you.
It's so sad, and sad, but I'm very sad.
It's a very sad story, so it's so sad.
It's so sad, so
it's sad.
It's so cold.
It's
so dark.
It's the future.
It's a big hope.
I'll never forget.
it's all broken right now for realsies hold on it's like
mega broken right now
let's see if i can fix it
let's see probably it won't be fixed completely but you know
i could try i could try i could try a little bit more
just you know come up to the window instead there's
a ghost in this classroom there's a ghost in this classroom
looks like you're grabbing me though out there I want she's
coming I'll just stay right here this is fine probably she
came from on the floor.
I
try singing.
I try singing.
I I
I I Like a Like a
Like a I was I was Was Tossed I Yeah
Yeah I I The wind's going to fall down When did it come?
Please,
please please don't worry Don't worry about it Please tell
me My own My own thoughts Oh
I'm going
backwards So
Watch my head
I'm trying to be cute, but I can't because my head is like a
freaking, what is this?
I'm like an owl.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, I still can't remember.
The smile, the angry face, the angry face I love you!
It's a bit strange, right?
I know it, but you didn't know
I'm all jumbled.
Wait, I'm jumbled.
Oh, sorry that auto-played.
I'm not singing that song.
I'm all jumbled.
I'm not jumbled.
My head is spinning around.
Hold on.
I'm gonna fix myself again, maybe.
As much as I can.
Wait.
Oh, wait, that actually worked.
Wow, crazy.
I still can't turn my head though.
So strange, so strange.
Every day we're jumbling.
I'm jumbled.
No longer.
Only a little jumbled.
Hold on, I'm going to try.
Ah!
I'm sorry, it's so scuffed.
Announcement in 15 minutes.
Since I've completely thrown away the plot of this.
Everything is not working.
Wait.
I can't see.
Hold on, I'm going to turn a little more.
Uh.
we're fine.
We're not fine, but we're dealing with it.
We're dealing with it.
We're not fine, but we're, I'm trying not to crash out.
We're not crashing out.
We're just dealing with
it.
Okay.
Let's sing another summer song.
Why am I holding the mic in my hand that I need to type in?
Um,
uh, Summer Song.
These were all supposed to be already fixed and already
decided, but I, um, uh, uh, too busy trying to fix
everything else okay hold on let me double check this
okay oh my gosh how did you know what it was somebody
guessed it how did you know Oh The
The The The The Obey The Baka The Mining The The But I know
that, but still, I'm so glad to be at the end of the day.
In the summer, in the rain and the rain, the
thaw-thaw-thaw-tow, the green-gown, the lights, the megas,
the green light, I'm going to see your beautiful face
In the
middle of the night Just a little bit of time I'm going to
see your happiness I'm
going to see you One more time I'm
going to see your beautiful
I'm sorry, everything keeps auto playing for some reason.
I'll try to rotate myself, but I can't figure out how to do
it.
Hold on, you're just going to have to deal with me for a
sec?
Everything's bad.
I keep trying to fix stuff.
I only make it worse.
Me singing emotional songs, twisting in the air.
One second, I'm gonna try to fix it again.
Everything is bad?
Everything is bad!
And this is my song about how everything is bad!
It's bad!
It's so bad!
Everything is bad!
Everything!
Everything sucks!
Computers suck!
3D sucks!
Everything's bad!
Nothing works!
Why doesn't anything work anymore?
Why doesn't anything work?
You look so short down there.
Sorry, I made the window so much small.
There you go.
That's a little bit better, but I didn't want the point was
I didn't want you to see my legs, but I guess it's fine.
When you're a ghost, you can believe that everything's bad.
everything is bad when you're a ghost probably let's do one
more song and then announcement maybe do you guys want to
hear the very awesome announcement i know you do please say
yes please say yes please say yes please say yes
oh okay let's just do the next one one from here, I guess.
Wait, sorry, I can't figure out where to move myself.
There I go.
Here's the next song.
But I'll
do this one.
I'm so sweaty.
I'm so sweaty, you guys.
I consider this a summer song, I don't know.
I don't care anymore.
Are you a dreamer?
Oh no, wait, sorry, one second.
The, uh, they disconnected.
One second, I'm stuck down here.
One second, that, you heard was my since we're just
connecting.
Will they reconnect?
Everything is...
How did I...
How did my own...
Oh, this is...
like you and I look straight at you.
I want to find you, I want to find you.
I believe in you.
There's nothing that can't be anything.
I'm going to sing like a miracle.
My thoughts change everything.
I
am a dreamer
I'll be in the world So what do you want?
If it's not true,
I'm not afraid.
The birds are the wind, I'm going to go on a journey, going
on a journey from tomorrow to tomorrow.
I want to say, I want to say, I want to say this one only
one of my own existence.
I'm going to pray, like a star, like a small light.
Are you guys ready for the announcement?
Announcement, announcement, announcement time!
Well, as you can see, the legend of this ghost is real, but
also kind of cursed.
The ghost of the classroom is a little cursed.
If you couldn't tell, she's, she struggles a lot every,
every day.
so i think maybe maybe 3d is too hard and i want to sit down
i want to sit down so i'm going to bring my chair back over
i'm just going to roll this bad boy back and i'm just going
to ignore my motion and uh i'll set up uh my I'll set up my
2D.
Sorry, I tried.
This is what I get for trying, I guess.
Anyway.
Okay, announcement!
Exciting, huge, big announcement.
Whatever could it be?
It's so awesome!
Yippee, yippee!
Okie-dokie!
I might take a few minutes to get set up after the
announcement, so...
Hey, Kuzai!
Hey, have you heard that legend?
They say a girl died here at the beach a long time ago
during summer vacation.
Apparently she was waiting for her date, but they never
showed up.
She waited and waited, humming a light-hearted tune.
But when her date never showed, she was heartbroken.
And so, they say she walked into the sea and never came
back.
And now, if you come to the beach at night, you might hear
humming that same tune.
Pretty creepy, right?
Yippee,
yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee!
It's so summery!
And so I wanted a summer album!
And you guys will be able to see my summer album!
But it's not just a summer outfit.
It's also other stuff.
Oh, you'll just have to come and see.
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
I'll post the full double silhouettes later.
Actually, I don't know how chat and everything looks.
Hold on.
Once I took this away, I wonder what it would look like.
Oh, ah, ah, ah, get away, get away!
Aisha, wait, I'm still holding my mic, I guess this is fine.
Kabedona Tempo, that was like a true like anime like moment.
Where it's like, that was like a true anime moment where.
It's like, cow, what are you doing?
We cow.
Hold on, I gotta turn on my fan before I have a heat stroke.
Whatever you hear is everything falling apart around me.
Let's sing a couple more songs.
Oh, I meant to put up the outfit.
There we go.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Yay.
New outfit.
debut new album new album debut sorry for the absolute
scuffedness of the stream i have been trying all day to set
it up so um so sorry but everything decided to crash and
burn oh but let me take off these sensors that are making me
hot and sweaty
another sensor yeah okay well I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
sing a couple more songs sorry it's a all my karaoke reason
I'm traumatized of karaoke right now karaoke streams are
traumatizing me at the moment because everything is
everything is bad let's do let's do Let's do...
This song.
Wait, let me take off these ones too.
Alright, that's cool!
Okay.
Let's sing.
This song is a summer song, right?
You would not believe your eyes of 10 million fireflies as I
fell asleep Cause they fit teardrops everywhere You'd think
me rude, but I would just stand and stare I'd like to make
myself believe That planet Earth turns slowly It's hard to
stay, I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep Cause everything
is never as it seems Cause I'd get a thousand hugs From
10,000 lightning bugs As they try to tea
And it's all caught beneath my bed A disco ball is just
hanging by a thread I'd like to make myself believe Now that
it all turns Slowly It's hard to stay I'd rather stay awake
Cause everything is never as it seems And I fall asleep This
guy is so loud Leave my door open just a crack Please take
me away from me I feel like such an insomniac Please take me
away from me Why do I tire of counting sheep Please take me
away from me When I'm far too tired to fall asleep The 10
million fireflies, I'm weird cause I hate goodbyes, I got
misty eyes as they said farewell, but I'll know where
several are, if my dreams get real bizarre, cause I saved a
few and I keep them in a jar.
I'd like to make myself believe that planet Earth does.
Slowly, it's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm
asleep Cause everything is never as it seems I'd like to
make myself believe That planet Earth turns Slowly, it's
hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Everything is never as it seems I'd like to make myself
believe That planet Earth turns slowly It's hard to say that
I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep Because my dreams are
bursting at the seams
It's summer because it's fireflies Fireflies are a summer.
Right?
They're a summer activity.
Yeah!
Agreed!
So true!
Yay!
Fireflies.
But I feel like there's so many fewer fireflies around
nowadays, huh?
Okay.
right the silhouette reminds me of a certain character from
galaxy angel
are you trying to say mint i got a bunch in my backyard it's
nice oh that's so nice i saw one before i moved and it was
like dying on the ground it was actually quite depressing
no people nowadays really wouldn't believe their eyes it's
It's true.
Yeah.
Let's not think about sad stuff.
Let's think about summer.
Summer, summer, summer, summer.
Summer, summer, summer.
Let's do...
Here, here.
This one will cheer you guys up.
Just take a listen.
Call this one the campfire song song Let's gather around the
campfire and sing our campfire song Our CAPIFIRE ESONG song
And if you don't think that we can sing it If you just sing
along C-A-F-I-R-E-S-O-G song C-A-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G song And if
you don't think that we can sing it faster than your rod but
it will help it, we just sing along.
Thank you, R-L-C-A-M-B-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G song!
Patrick!
Well,
if you just sing along...
Wait, I wanna sing it with Patrick this time.
Okay, here we go.
Let's try again.
All right, Patrick, sing with me.
Let's gather around the campfire and sing our campfire song.
I can't get the timing on that.
M-B-R-E-S-O-N-G song.
If you don't think we can sing it faster than you're wrong,
but it'll help if you just sing along.
Boom, boom, boom.
C-A-M-B-F-I-R-E-S-O-I-G song.
And if you don't think we can sing it faster than you're
wrong, but it'll help if you just sing along.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-G song.
Patrick!
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-G song!
Good!
Help if you just sing along.
I want to hear just Patrick this time.
Patrick solo.
Let's gather around the campfire and sing our campfire song.
That's not SpongeBob.
Who are you?
And if you don't think that we can sing it, it's faster than
your own.
But it'll help if you just sing along.
Boom, boom, boom.
I use a
program called Kara fun for like most of my karaoke songs
and they allow you to have like the singers usually and like
backup singers and things like that it's really great and
then you can also hear oh like they'll get people that sound
tangentially similar to the original do they have ripped
pants that's not a summer song but
they do
daily dialogue congrats on my side that I went to blue it
all sky high and now she won't even spare a passing glance
all just because I
I know
I shouldn't mope around our shrinkers but the pain feels so
much worse because winding with no one is a lot less fun
than a burn from the sun or sand in your buns.
Now I learned a lesson I won't soon forget.
So listen and you won't regret.
Be true to yourself.
Don't miss your chance.
And you won't end up like the fool who ripped his hand.
The ripping sound effect is just too good.
Holy cow.
Yay, okay.
I'll do two more songs that I had written down.
This one is a fan favorite, I think.
I think it's a kind of summary.
It's a summary sounding song, so I feel like it's, it works.
At this point, everything is lost.
Please just watch my outfit debut.
Just come to my outfit debut.
Please search something I don't know.
Please, please watch my outfit debut.
Please watch my outfit debut.
Also, the song that was playing in the little trailer.
Didn't that sound so nice?
Kiss me Out of a bearded barley Nightly Beside the green
green grass Swing, swing Swing the spinning stuff You wear
those shoes and I will wear that dress Oh Kiss me With a
milky twilight,
The silver moon's sparkling So kiss me
Kiss me Down by the broken treehouse Swing me Up on its
hanging tire Ring, ring We'll take the trail marked on your
father's map Oh, kiss me Kiss me Beneath the milky twilight
Lead me Silver
moon sparkly So kiss me
Kiss me Beneath the milky twilight Lead me Out on
silver moon sparkly So kiss me
So kiss me
I realized I didn't put up the swords!
Yay!
I'll do one last song.
And then I shall I have to, I forgot to set up a I forgot to
set up a thing for Or up a tweet.
Thank you for the summer dance, you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm going to do this song.
It's funny because when I was like, what are some...
What are some summer songs?
This song kept coming up, and I was like, maybe it's a
summer song in Japan.
Show the squirrels.
No!
Guys, it's a pretty cute outfit.
I'm not going to lie.
Not going to lie.
So, a little less than two weeks.
I'm excited.
I kind of decided to announce it a bit early.
Because, I don't know.
I don't know.
Okay, I sing.
This one kept coming up.
I was like, you know what?
This is fine.
This is fun.
I like the song anyway.
So, wait, hold on.
I have to change the key, I think.
One second.
Okay, okay, that should be fine.
If that's not fine, then I just die.
I love this song!
Yeah,
the big guy!
Yeah, I got the big guy
Yeah, the big guy!
My whole life will be I'm gonna lose The stage goes down
Image-dark-a-like I'm not your own No, it's just gonna be
like It's a nice, nice, nice
Image of a somber Noggini, zibasa Even though I'm sure
you'll be able to stop All my love
Uncertained in a dream No, no, no, no No, no, no, no No, no,
no, no No, no, no No, no, I can't So I'm gonna stay I can't
imagine No, no No, no, no
Please come
save my new outfit and tell your friends and your grandma to
come see you i hope you guys will like it thank you thank
you thank you thank you sorry for so much scuff and sorry
for being sad about it and i hope you guys had fun still i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry okay bye bye thank you bye bye thank
you bye bye thank you bye bye you sorry thank you bye-bye
thank you sorry thank you bye-bye thank you sorry bye-bye
thank you sorry bye thank you sorry bye thank you sorry bye
thank you sorry bye thank you sorry bye